[Music]
does his
juice drinking offend you a lot of
things been happening i guess we should
probably start with the one who probably
gets the most clicks
hi sisters james charles here and
welcome back to my youtube channel
as you guys can see we are not in our
normal filming location and that's
because for today's video
slurring already the winnie all right
probably no good
he's not even he's one of those he's a
young kid you know but 19 year olds have
got better control of their lips
i mean i imagine he's pretty good with
his lips i have a
very special announcement that i have
literally been waiting to tell you guys
the use of the word literal pisses me
off in 2019
literally wait he literally stopped
saying just literal whatever the [__]
sometimes you go i saw a car crash today
and people go
literally yes literally yeah it wasn't a
metaphor he wears some outlandish [__]
wow so we've seen his instagram recently
you mean the
butt cheeks for a man i mean it's a good
ass you want to see mine because i feel
like i have a better backside
not really it would worry me if i liked
it as well um so
but the thing with him is he cheats
doesn't he puts those butt cheek
injections in and all that no that's a
false accusation
i'll come off no no james was here right
now he go how far is his eyes
he's been injecting in his eyes right
you guys i swear to god you guys i have
literally
stopped saying literally guys we've just
had a little conversation
but there are over 24 dates in 24 cities
all around the united states we'll be
playing games you guys will be coming up
we'll be doing
q and a's of course there'll be music as
well and duh
a whole lot of instagram selfies right
okay now what's the good stuff what the
good stuff is yeah is
how much money this [__] is
about to make yeah it
is madness you will be able to choose
from four different ticket packages from
general admission
all the way to an extremely limited
number of our exclusive
sister vips people who pay for the vips
they don't get the same
experience do they they get to meet the
sky they get well allegedly
no literally literally do you want to
know how much how much am i starting out
at just to get there
50 60 just to get in wow just to get in
vip tickets
what he's selling about and not the
resale because you know the resale's
gonna be double trouble
ticketmaster 500.
his fans have gone mental about this
online and he's now
like backtracking oh wow we're not going
to say
sort of eminem sure we're not saying a
music a legend or anything sure we're
saying this guy
for [__] makeup on something you can
do from your home
on youtube that's actually a really good
point like for example take will and
stephen right there to a
lot of material you've never seen before
they're probably looking at the same
crowd that
he's got no you get closer to them you
feel like you can touch them almost
sometimes you can wait for them after
the show and touch them if you want yeah
i'm not it's not an accusation
the point is that stuff you can't see
you can see him do [__] makeup on his
channel this is like face painting
back in when you were a kid and you went
to a kid's party and had their face
painted he's a glorified [__]
face painter at a kid's party and he's
charging 500 [__]
we're in the wrong [__] game lawrence
welcome to brian the beauty queen
and uh i'm gonna be doing your makeup
today we're gonna have so much fun it's
gonna be awesome i literally i'm going
to paint your [__] face
and charge you 500 quid just to watch
yeah pay up [__]
i met kim kardashian once
[Music]
can we get a picture of brian painting
his face to the lion king music
honestly women are the goldmine of
youtube you guys will buy
any old [__] i rate you so highly women
hate you so for today's video i thought
it would be so
much fun to come downstairs to the kitty
kitchen did you just say the kitty
kitchen just call it the [__] kitchen
[__] kitty kitchen i'm gonna go to
the pooy toilet and we're gonna go into
the shitty shower
i could recreate my starbucks order that
i get every single day
from scratch let's get started
what is this what the [__] is this [__]
hey next next one
it actually feels quite good when you do
that for this video i am wearing my
custom pinkity drinkity hoodie that was
made for me by two my fan pages
zoe and brooke i love you guys the
absolute most he's even got better fans
than us rather fantastic they did
you got all those packages that day and
you threw them on the bin you went this
is all dog [__]
don't tell them you literally went which
[__] morons made this
adele's getting a divorce no no that
means we get another album
yeah i'm just going to slate the [__]
out of that corner he's probably sitting
somewhere going oh [__] me what you're
going to put in this hold my boat
can i just say i would definitely [__] a
dull and marry adult so this guy
if if she'd be with him why not me i
mean i'm a better version of that let's
be honest details have been slowly
coming out about
why adele ended her seven plus year
relationship
and two-year marriage to simon kaneki
koniki kunichi apparently they're more
like friends than lovers which means she
needs some dick
to adele and her 174 million bank home
you are back on the market let's take
you out
i like the idea that she's like she's
going never mind i'll find
someone like you and brian's in the
audience going
i look a bit like him he's actually
bought an e-fit and he's just going huh
yeah i mean why not with her having kids
now she doesn't need a man who's
constantly sort of wanting to be with
her she wants someone who she can sort
of meet up every now and then so i've
have her own time
sure also i like them thick she's a
thick girl let's get this in
i mean life's evolving lawrence you know
people are on tinder these days uh i'm
not in tinder
although one lasting message me the
other day saying i think you've just
matched with my mother on tinder oh
that's lovely that wasn't me although
what is your mother
anyway clearly she has no taste adele is
available she's with she's been with
this whole ball looking guy i'm
definitely a hobo
looking guy i mean yeah look at you
i'm an improvement that's all i'm saying
why not yeah adele
i like thick women anyway let's that's
that's let's get it on i don't know if
any woman's ever attracted to a man who
goes yeah why not no no i mean
adult um i've been a big fan for quite
some time now yeah and
what's your favorite song the one that
everyone sings god we have the topic
the one that everyone cries out good uh
yeah yeah
really got me game of thrones is back uh
the biggest tv show
in history jon snow found out he was
actually king of the seven kingdoms he
then told
daenerys that she wasn't best pleased
about it because she thought she was the
heir and he's actually
the uh and living a lie the whole entire
time everyone's been lying
staffordshire's his now maisie williams
who plays arya stark
had sex on the show now in reality she's
22 years old and
probably had sex quite some time ago but
on
on the show she was basically growing up
in front of
our eyes as like a young kid so a lot of
people they're not really happy
yeah they're saying she didn't need to
do that it wasn't in character she's not
a sexual
person i don't really know if the
character has to
sort of regularly masturbate on the show
to prove that they're sexual in any way
at all there's been complaints made
you're joking this wasn't my expectation
of this
fictional character that you decided the
root of she once
fed killed a couple of guys baked them
in a pie
fed them to a dad slit the dad's throat
after he ate his own kid
yeah so she was fine doing that yeah but
none of that
is suck on some dick in the show she's
often the one who takes control of
situations and in this situation
dominant
she was the one who said hey we're gonna
die tonight and i want to know what it's
like
so you are getting [__] and to be
quite honest with you i sort of thought
i wish more women would say things like
that us
right you know if she inspires a few out
there
um we just need an apocalypse to get
them into that sort of frame of mind
yeah i actually had to address this on
twitter and what
so if you're uncomfortable about it my
mum and dad have probably seen that
scene get a grip basically but again
it's acting
and literally these are all the replies
of people
the debate rages on the debate over what
brian this fictional character
she have [__] gentry which was i think
it was quite poetic because in the first
episode the two dads of these two
said you know what we could join our
houses one day but they didn't realize
that those were the two who'd get it
very poetic and that's the game of
thrones update for this week's
true news charlie theron charlize the
wrong i believe is the correct
pronunciation charlie's theron
yeah he's got a young daughter and
people are making a big song of dante
because she's raising her child
as transgender charlize theron says she
thought she was raising a little boy
until the then three-year-old jackson
looked at her and said
i'm not a boy from that moment on the
oscar-winning actress by the way that
qualifies her to be a doctor
embraced the fact that she was raising a
transgender girl when i was three i i
think i thought for a good week there i
was an
elephant and then a grizzly bear the
week after i'm i'm sure all i'm saying
is you're a big child
three-year-olds probably aren't really
equipped to make sort of life-changing
decisions
right uh health 13 year olds on maybe
just sort of slow your role there before
confirming
everything i'm not saying that this
child is not
in fact transgender i'm just saying it's
a huge leap to come out and say this at
this point isn't it you know
maybe we want to just calm the [__] down
before we start playing around with
hormones or it's just one
it's just one of those things where you
end up being adopted by a hollywood
mother and next thing you know you're
you're telling their old thoughts and
she's going
yeah don't get me wrong i completely
support people's idea of being able to
be
whatever you want to be but i i think
you need to reach an age where you
understand
genders as a concept before you can say
whether you are
or on one or the other for a short time
belief that was batman my mother did not
build me a batcave
and you've never forgiven her no
ultimately fair enough and she pays the
price for it on a daily basis um but it
turns out the ground in burton was too
hard what i want to say
right now if charlie theron is watching
yeah you see
have accepted the the decision of the
three-year-old on
on the agenda don't go lobbing the knob
off yet yeah i think what she then said
while they were discussing over sort of
peas at dinner and went i'm a girl um
and they went absolutely let's get him
straight to the hospital it's not how it
works doctor
we need this dick off stuff one little
youtuber story before we move on i
wanted to cover one of my
sort of original youtubers i watched and
was a bit of an inspiration to me was
buggy
a guy who uh struggled with the way he
looked for many years
he was clinically obese uh he just
wasn't happy with a few things about
himself and he's been on a sort of
personal journey of progression this is
one of the first videos i remember
seeing a buggy
oh wow look at that poetry
poetry in motion this is him now right
this is him now here he's coming at you
what's up
ladies and gentlemen of youtube
boogie2988 coming out at your level
again through the power
of the internet and this is a pretty
exciting video for me um
for those of you who have noticed
throughout the years my terribly
maintained and awful rotten teeth not
only is it the weight loss
it's his teeth he's been on this big
journey now he's lost a lot of weight i
mean talking hundreds a lot
like i think maybe 200 pounds or
something like that maybe more and now
he's had
uh the surgery done check out the
difference in the big guy
oh my god you're a different guy
i would never thought it made that big
of a difference i really i really didn't
realize
i just want to say it this guy inspired
me to start youtube one of the people
who did anyway i'm just really happy to
see yeah
because there was a minute three years
ago and i i remember thinking he talked
a lot about losing the weight he talked
about self-improvement
but we've been hearing about that from
yeah for a few years
and there was a part of me that thought
never really going to do it are you you
know what i mean and now to see him
doing it
i'm just like [__] go on son so feel
good vibe
yeah feel good on the true news i like
that get a pinky drink good for you
buggy we're supporting you
unfortunately yeah bit of negativity no
no no
another it seems like a weekly thing now
ufc fighter has been
arrested until i said what in a cell
but not the cage he's used to darren
till arrested in tenerife spain
for trashing hotel and stealing a taxi
stealing a taxi he broke furniture and
emptied fire extinguishers
they ordered a taxi afterwards and when
the driver was putting their bags in the
boot two individuals one of which was
till
took control of the car and sped off
towards
la salad they were caught by police and
apprehended
till known as the gorilla recently lost
the fight and um he was on a bit of a
bender do you think i like that he's
letting his hair down but just
sort of calm down paul isn't it just
the disappointing thing is this probably
happens on a weekly basis in tenerife
because english people when they go
abroad are
but in tenerife they're just going
perfectly normal you're english yeah
absolutely
cool there we go any you don't want to
charge me this happens all the time hey
don't worry about that
thank you carl's fine isn't it yeah
absolutely yeah you're not coming back
to dinner
you not anytime soon cheers bye-bye
mcgregor he's all right he hasn't done
anything wrong
yeah um he just went home to his local
boxing club and did a charity boxing
match
that's nice raise money for kids bearing
in mind conor mcgregor
normally gets paid about 100 million to
lace the gloves up he just did it
for a little knock at his hometown
boxing club where he started like
because he if he goes in here and this
other guy
lands a lucky punch he makes the life of
this other guy and all of a sudden
people are questioning his credibility
and right so he's risking it a little
bit but credit doom for going in there
and doing
something good for his hometown boxing
can we just say the other way credit to
the other guy who chose to spar with him
who also this wasn't a spoiler could
have caught hands
they went they went for it as you'll see
here
[Applause]
[Music]
wow obviously um the class showed
as the contest went on it seemed like it
was all done in good spirits and
one thing i thought when i watched this
was it's nice to see him doing something
that shows the humble side of him
and not flashing the cache or whatever
and also
you don't really see a lot of big name
fighters doing a little event like this
in a little [__] boxing club like
sure
maybe don't call it [__] no but it
it isn't [__] the glitz and glamour
that we're used to seeing him in and i
like that
that's the mcgregor i'm a fan of the one
who will fight anyone anywhere and just
get in and not care and love fighting
i hope we see him back in the the cage
soon how are mates we've had him on the
podcast vidal
riley now training me in boxing
he's got a fight coming up he's won his
last two fights by knockout
just wanted to give it a bit of a shout
out because it's on pay-per-view online
you can click the link in the
description below if you want to order
that and watch it live we're going to
watch it live
and the guy's fighting you know is a
level up we've seen vidal smoke his
first two opponents in 30 seconds each
this guy's on another he's knocked out
what 14 of us
maybe we could show a little bit mo so
this is the guy who does fighting
the point is as you can see here this
guy can punch hard this guy looks
vicious he's probably juice to [__] and
i i i
can't say nobody probably i don't see
what i want but the problem is uh
vadan's having to go over to dubai this
is sort of his
neck of the woods and uh i don't think
the testing is a stringent so i
i think they're setting vidal up for a
very difficult third fight he's got like
14 15 knockouts i don't think he's being
beaten
he was in a tournament recently where he
won three fights in a single night so
this is like a real
serious challenge we're rooting for the
doll we're going to be watching you
can't do just put the link in the
description below for that if you want
to watch this
brian have you ever wanted an extreme
tan that's right
[Music]
other girls were like i can't live
without having my nails done this is not
the other way
i just can't live without having a
talent first off it's so [__]
dangerous to be addicted to these
tanning beds like
obviously you can get skin cancer and
[__] die for a start is it about not
accepting yourself or the way you are
just like miserable people do miserable
things no but i feel sorry for in that
respect because i think whenever you're
willing to put your life on the line
yes in order to change the way you look
you
have a problem yeah there's there's
therapy needed there there's not
some beds needed there's therapy
probably drying your skin out to such a
heavy degree that you're aging yourself
rapidly so
i mean she wanted she's probably 20
years old like five years
you're you're gonna look an extra 10
years older at least
at least she might look 40 by the time
you're 20. she's gonna regret this [__]
a lot so basically this is what it looks
like it's quite easy to get
everyone's able to get it like like
there's loads of facebook pages and
they're like
cell and tan like the nasal sprays are
really really big at the minute
nasal sprays i mean you get that for
hair fever not for a [__] time pet
it's extreme and do you think she's
blackfaced i don't think she's
intentionally doing that i think she's
so unhappy with how she looks she just
wants to look very very very tanned and
she's taking it to a degree where it's
almost like anorexia uh where you are
become oblivious to how you look so
other people can see it in you but you
can't see it in yourself and i think
part of it is it's so subliminal in
modern society that people fetishize
like what a black body is as opposed to
a white body maybe
there's a a specific color that's
becoming fashionable so you see
uh black artists trying to look a bit
lighter skinned you see uh for example
nicki minaj they're changing how they
look from when they were
born there's this perfect like image
that as women are sort of all trying to
go for isn't there and she's just being
sucked up into that i'll say this to a
boyfriend i mean i know i can't talk but
[__] me that haircut i didn't know my
ass
see i personally like that that i have a
thing for like kind of ridiculously big
thick bums on women right and if i seen
that walking down the street i'd be like
what women do a lot of them they're
doing these women do these
pants where they sort of pack everything
in and it looks all smooth and
so you don't really know what it looks
like when it gets out of those
pants right but i would imagine it would
look damn good regardless
you don't worry about cellulite or any
of those things on the bottom do a [__]
no jiggle it up baby
right let's take a look
courtney barnes has one very
attention-grabbing asset
her unusually large bum do you think she
likes the attention does it ever worry
that someone does this just for the
attention people do a lot of things for
attention but specifically obviously
women
they want to look good and i and i get
that and then there's this image of
big horses look better if you're
injecting [__] into your ass like people
have died from that you know what i mean
so you better know what the [__] you're
doing shit's supposed to come out the
ass not in the ass well you can put
things up the arse if you want but
that's another story right pop knob in
fanny
oh my
deliver a package to you oh i'm sorry i
got a late delivery for you girl
i'll be on time for that my butt is just
not set up as much as it used to
i could see a little discoloration
but other than that other than the
sagging discoloration everything good
that's not great is it take a look at
the booty
okay this by far is officially the
biggest booty i've ever seen in my life
see i can feel lumps and bumps in here
oh i can definitely feel the lumps and
the bumps oh wow he is getting
[__] semi erected at least what
nothing more
i'm unfortunately seeing more and more
of these cases
of silicone injections to the buttocks
so when he's saying lumps and bumps it's
it's the silicon this
um thing that they're injecting isn't
dissolving into the bomb and becoming
like tissue
but it's just hardening and just sitting
there you saw this woman on the street
and you go damn girl let me see that
booty
she brings it over and then she says you
can't touch it go ahead but you're
feeling the lumps and the bumps you go
oh good or do you go damn girl no i like
new experiences
i just feel sorry for people who end up
with these problems you know i mean it's
it's sad
i have a big ass that i can't get rid of
but ultimately we're trapped in a
business relationship
brian brian brian brian brian we dwell
in the real world
other people dwell in heaven this is my
morning routine
and i do this because in mark 1 35
it says that jesus waking up very early
in the morning
he went to a quiet place and there he
prayed
and jesus lived in such a way that we're
called to live as he did
and so jesus he set aside the side of
her head there
reminds me a little bit of elvis do you
know the way her hair sort of swept
right back across her yeah but do you
ever just look out the window and just
laughs
[Laughter]
i'm so empty dead inside the moment i
step outside of my bedroom door
i'm going to be attacked with lies upon
lies upon lies from the enemy
because we live in a world that is ruled
by the father of lies
who's the father of lies it's ruled by
the father is that donald trump
no no no so it is crucial and it is
essential
that i get my armor of god on and i
fill my heart with his truth the thing
is i'm trying to be a bit nicer on this
show
and really but she's making it [__]
hard not like that she seems very sweet
she's a [__] nut kiss
let's be honest she's an absolute nutter
she's sitting talking to herself
rocking back and forth on her bed
laughing out the window before she goes
out going
i love my truth i know my truth i'm
going to fill my heart with my god
alma she's talking absolute nonsense so
come on you fill our lives with absolute
nonsense
i start right there when i wake up and
the moment that my eyes open
i start singing i start singing because
i can't help it
oh [__] hat yeah but the weird thing
is
she goes my mind's telling me no party
can't make it sound sensual anymore you
dumb [__] he's a sexual predator
the joke was on her not him i can't help
it my god is so
good in the morning he brings me word of
his
unfailing love if you're hearing voices
when you first wake up and no one's in
the room with you you're probably
schizophrenic or your father's under the
bed just whispering god is good
god is good god it's god and i get so
excited because just
as the sun rises i get to rise and be in
his presence and i get to praise him
i like to praise you like i should
i want i want god to become greater and
i want i want him to become
all the more powerful are you trying to
get and prove god are you yeah i think
it's pretty perfect all right yeah
divine pretty good generally speaking
god's up there going
arrogant little insubordinate
[__] do you think you're gonna think of
things that i haven't thought of
you think i've got things to work on i'm
a senior trim get a [__] haircut look
i want him to get the fame
i want him to get the likes god's out uh
middle of manhattan just going
hey guys i got all the things
yeah he's in times square just going i
just want all the fame
yeah okay so i go to turn on my lamp
and the moment that i turn on my lamp
i'm just reminded of how
good god is she is
she can't even switch on a [__] light
without giving this [__] some
credit like
literally thank the electrician who
clubbed the [__] lighting
you i think this is about to get really
good ready
my heart you have to you have to express
[Music]
it
for some reason neither of us really
grew up with a love for cooking
i love the fact that they struggle to
admit that they can't cook for their
husbands at all yeah so it's like
everything they preach about
old-fashioned values about
you know homemaking and being the wife
in the home and stuff like that
and it's like didn't go the hallway did
you you you kept up with everything that
benefited you and you ditched a bit that
involves you working hard in the kitchen
well that's not really the like
women these days right someone's bitter
okay so something we've been seeing a
lot on social media on the internet you
guys have seen it too are these meal
subscription boxes
and i've been seeing that and like i
wonder
like realistically how legitimate they
are and so home chef actually reached
out to us
you've done this for a brand deal you're
wrapping up your word of jesus
in a business model just what business
and jesus just wanted
these hypocritical bastards i love how
they and they act like they're all
together now
and that they're just doing this to
spread the word of god and they're like
well you know girl defined use our
coupon code
and you can get yourself four boxes if
you're a lazy [__] like us and you call
me
if you can't be asked to cook for your
husband either and you're a deadbeat
wife
right get up three bucks of food
delivered to the house not
play it in the microwave shut the
[__] door bob's your uncle it's him
satisfied
parody disgrace parody if you all know
zach and me you know that we absolutely
love
exploring new places traveling and
particularly
camping and going to epic national parks
white people fun
white people fun white people fun fun
white people doing things intense
fun white people driving i quite like
coming
right yeah i'd like to go coming with a
girl it would be fun she is in her
campfire
no i'm just yeah just you and her
yeah you know doing the marshmallows and
the fire then um
under the stars wow you'd sleep with no
tents i mean we'd
go outside for a minute always keep the
frying pan close
yeah we all remember
[Music]
yeah i was thinking available it but now
that the girl defines us have said no
then maybe not i'm really starting to
see how much kit they've got but also on
the other hand i can't be off the couch
for myself so i don't know
one of them great boxes yeah i found out
about sexual abuse and commercial abuse
talking about sexuality is something
every single one of us can relate to
because
we're all sexual beings right like
whether you're young old
single married it doesn't matter yeah we
are all sexual by design
i think that should be decent in bed why
are you judging me she's objects
she's confident though it means what its
purpose is
how we handle our desires as we think
about all things regarding
our sexuality it is so important for us
as christian women
to go back to the author and creator of
sexuality and that is god i know when
i'm feeling sexual i like to
dust off an old big book and just read
through it god remember when moses
parted the season
[__] me those could be my legs it's when
jesus does the lepers that really gets
me
no well no that limbs falling off when
he walk waltz through
those waves like yeah he owned the place
oh like jesus
when jesus fed the five thousand do you
know how much the vip tickets were
five hundred hmm
you got something i'm with jesus
it's not a terrible part of our life
it's like something god is turning a
blind eye to
like oh i don't want to see that i don't
want to talk about that i'm embarrassed
by that he cares about it if anything
god's looking directly at it he is going
what are you doing read the [__]
instructions no
stop sucking it especially after it's
been in that oh god
blue van man has been reaching out to
the local community who's doing a conor
mcgregor
folks i'm doing something different
today i've had an email from a lad
called jake and he says can you come and
review me dad's
butchers so i've come over to easley
tony's butchers
here's tony can i just say though right
even though he's a bit daft than that i
would hazard a guess let's say he's 40.
i think if you give him a tv show for
example on a bbc two
7 p.m immediately after the one show
he'd been seeing it already
he would be fine like he's just so
down-to-earth i think that's what i like
about but he doesn't take himself too
seriously he's quite relaxed he's doing
really good here i've seen youtubers
who've done
hundreds of videos [__] the bed with
when they haven't got the benefit of all
the editing and all that crap they make
them look good he is a natural this
is a follow-up to tony's butchers last
week
in east league i had last week some
sausages and some bacon from
tony's in east league on the uh is it
main street to the high street
if you go to eastleigh you'll see it if
you're driving through
instead of turning left towards the uh
car park and the fire station
go on and it's this i think it's the
second shopping on the left-hand side
can you be more specific mate for foxy
i know when i drive into east league
from any angle it's the second job on
the right the wife's cooked it
she's the way she cooks it is uh most
people just put a piece of steak in the
frying pan
we just like the air fat fry it seems to
just do everything
just nice what do you like about the
airfryer
does everything just does everything
just nice the visually impaired i'm
holding a piece of steak
up to the camera it looks in my opinion
very nice nice cocktail color
cookie color cocktail i'd say what color
is that
that's like a cookie now we go from
steak to mixed kebab
the title is fantastic yeah we just say
mix kebab
from supreme fishbowl at yeah i don't
know why the sound is out of sync now
to me we need to help this guy with his
titles on youtube titles are quite a big
thing
bvm you know keep it she's just sort of
miss kebab review
that that is enough i don't know why the
sound is out of sync yeah you don't you
you don't put i don't know why this is
outside
oh that chicken is
absolutely to die for he's just had
a real prime cut of steak and he didn't
react the way he's reacting to this
kebab
the sound's out of sync it's so badly
out of sync it looks like we're reading
his mind
yes what is this what is
this is a piece of art but he literally
looks behind him and he goes i have to
keep looking behind me
what's going on this is i'm not joking
if i thought this was a parody channel i
think this was performance art
and that he'd synced it up almost
perfectly it's amazing it's incredible
i think we've seen enough for one day
what a way to finish
the truest of all the news um blue
vermont attempting to reach
50 000 youtube subscribers um if you can
help us we're on the kickoff youtube
channel our football channel
yeah we're trying to i think we're
eighty thousand now we're trying to get
a hundred thousand
if you're into football do subscribe to
the football channel the links in the
description
below 100k probably should um
probably should end the video now but
can't seem to
think what else i should say probably
should tell them to
like and subscribe to this channel and
um
don't forget to check us out on spotify
and itunes
uh we're on all of the downloadables and
um
you can listen to this when you're
probably on journey in your car or when
you're walking to work or whatever
you're doing really
lovely so probably you've got real lives
i'm not like the youtuber but um
yeah should you get lunch yeah yeah good
yeah